wow
[Music]
interesting
but he's probably feeling the same way
that you cannot allow G6 by any
yeah well freeing the queen as quickly
as possible
yeah
but actually it can also get into some
very peaceful game right I mean exactly
like B3 B6 we should be tonight and then
maybe we play some
some cool stuff yeah G5
what is G5 I mean can I say well what is
this G5 no it cannot be here
no it's this is not not true
why not uh I mean we can just take and
the queen is coming back yeah how
now I play D6
no but it can't be that yeah do you
think pH and uh minus anticipated first
move B3
you probably anticipated it yeah no way
come on no this is no this is incredible
if it works no
b3g5 yeah
that was absolutely amazing
this is
you first of all fall fall from the
chair no I mean okay
what is happening bcg5 but I think you
should be able to give the queen no for
excellent position exactly this is what
I'm worried also yeah that I'm in TX
Knight F6 Queen G7
Queen H6 and then D6